Vladimir Putin visitó a su único Aliado
declarado el mandatario ruso llegó a
belarus junto con sus ministros de
defensa y relaciones exteriores con el
propósito de reafirmar la relación
bilateral política y militar además
acordaron el despliegue de unidades
militares rusas en territorio bielorruso
para realizar ejercicios tácticos
junto resistimos la presión de las
sanciones de Estados hostiles intentos
de aislar a Rusia y velarus de los
mercados globales coordinamos los pasos
para minimizar el impacto de las medidas
restrictivas y legales en las economías
de nuestros países y debo decir que lo
estamos haciendo con bastante confianza
y eficacia
Moscú y Minsk comparten una larga
historia de cooperación en 2020 el
kremlin ayudó a acabar con una oleada de
protestas en contra del presidente
Alexander lucasenscure y más
recientemente han desplegado una
agrupación militar conjunta que incluye
el entrenamiento de militares la
posesión de tanques armamento entre
otros
por lo que la reciente visita de Putin
aminsk avivó los temores en kiev sobre
una nueva ofensiva terrestre
la gente comenzará a gritar hoy Putin
vino aquí asustar a alguien por qué
Rusia siempre nos ha encontrado a mitad
de camino hoy no hay un solo problema
que no se haya resuelto nos encontramos
con la federación rusa a mitad de camino
en el momento más difícil la Cumbre
entre ambos líderes se producen un
momento en el que Ucrania cree que Rusia
podría lanzar una nueva ofensiva a gran
escala contra kiev en los primeros meses
de 2023